hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game between shree shrah and
mereloc Shikari and none other than
Vasily Evancho's now chances are you've
already seen this game as it's been
considered to be quite an upset
but actually was not gonna show this
game for two reasons but I'm gonna get
back to those two reasons at the end of
the video hopefully if I don't forget
now it's again it's a game from round
one of the some ways it gets
international chess tournament this is
the fifth edition of the tournament and
there are a lot of very strong players
in this tournament and this is the
resort where the tournament is taking
place so let's just check that out it's
a really huge photo so I'm gonna have to
do some special effects and by that I
mean I'm gonna drag the photo from right
to left so you can see the entire thing
this is the hotel where they're playing
and this is the nice beach there you can
see the waves and understand and
everything so I always say you know if
you become really good chess player you
will be able to visit places like these
and play chess you know there is nothing
better than that
and also here we have a very nice photo
of the two gentlemen there it is it's
from the official website of the salmon
we see this international chess festival
I will put a lot of useful links in the
description below there to their Twitter
feed to their official website and a lot
of interesting stuff interviews and so
on so if I will cover any more games
from this event you can enjoy everything
as well now I couldn't find any good
photos of the of younger shree shrah
Nomura like Shikari I used this one but
it's actually from a video from chess
base India as YouTube channel so I will
put a link to that video in the
description as well as there you can
learn a bit more about this young
gentleman because at the beginning of
beginning of this year he was rated some
2050 and by now he's already rated 20
250 and he won all of that rating in one
tournament he played the six and a half
out of seven in the Commonwealth
Championship and he really crushed it so
quite a you know quite a rising star
that face is event two here so without
further ado let's check out the game and
why this game is is so important so
let's see
it young shriek one has the white pieces
and he opens with d4 and here eventually
goes for c5 this is the benoni but this
is the old Benoni defense so surely she
won't simply proceed with the d5 like it
was a regular but only under this is the
most common reply in the old days you
could capture on c5 you know get a lose
the control of the center but nowadays
that's not really something some
appealing you could even go b6 and go
for the comer and gambit and then after
captures captures you will have complete
control of the center black will even
attack it would have to be 7 and it will
have it will be a very nice game of
course but for modern tastes and not
really a bar ok d5 with Knight to f6 c4
e6 Knight to c3 we have the main line of
the Benoni
captures captures we have d6 with this
is still in the waters of the main line
efore g 6f for this is the constant
variation of the of the Benoni
push up to g7 and now you might be
thinking okay but what if white pushes a
5 here that's what I was always thinking
when I was playing black in positions
like these it's not really a problem for
black you can simply go back with the
night and it seems that the pawn train
is overextended the point is now
attacked three times and while there are
some forced variations that allow white
to play this if you if you learn them or
if you if you're playing a clip playing
in a classical game you will most likely
be able to defend off this attack but
okay in this game Bishop to b5 that was
played that this comes with check and
now comes the night F to d7 well you can
block with both Bishop and the night
it's kind of a kind of a thing in the
benoni whenever it is a Bishop to b5
check comes usually one a block with it
this night because after this Bishop to
b5 there could be some ideas with E 5 so
better not make this night a target and
by doing this you have a very nice
control of the e5 square and ok Knight
to f3 with a6 Avant you immediately
questions what do you want to do with
the bishop trade it for the night of
course you don't want to do that so you
have to go back and now b5 so if I to
this having a very nice game as black in
the benoni he will push c4
at some point this night will come to c5
or if white pushes f5 then even if I
will be a very nice square for the night
he will Castle he has a very nice Bishop
on g7 always well for black so we have
castles castles King - h1 a nice
prophylactic move after c4 comes you
don't want to allow Queen to b6 or
Bishop to d4 at some points to come with
checks so a very useful move and now
rook to e8 and this has all been played
before a plenty of times I there are
over 200 games in the database from this
position with a three C for now pushing
the bishop back creating a nice square
for the knight and c5 the bishop to see
- and now comes Knights to c5 and here
there are some games in the database
that had this exact same position in
some of them f5 was played this is the
most common move here in one of them if
I was played were white one a nice game
but black blundered and also a non move
here was a Bishop to e3 but here young
sure each one makes a move that was not
played before so and E 5 + f5 are the
top engine recommendations the the movie
chuan played here is Knights to d4 and
it's actually the third move recommended
by the engine so I'm very interested is
this still in the in the lines of this
young gentleman's preparation or is this
now you know a move an original creative
move that would that was created over
the board I have no idea but you'll see
what he had in mind so Knight to d4 and
from this position we have a completely
new game and even Chuck finds a very
nice idea here he plays Bishop to g4
oversees the light square Bishop for
this knight on d4 the knight on d4 is a
very strong piece a black can't really
develop you have to keep an eye on c6
you don't wanna love something like
Knight to c6 also it's it's really a
nice centralized piece you just don't
want to give up your dark square Bishop
to get rid of it and your light square
Bishop on the other hand is a pretty
useless piece so why not trade it we
have Queen captures everyone goes for it
with Bishop captures on d4 and now comes
f5 and okay now the e5 square has been
made available for black so we have
Knight B to d7 this Knight is now at
some point coming to the 5 or maybe a
six depending on what white place f
captures and g 6f captures and g6 and
now comes B five okay this is a move 19
this is now the critical moment of the
game you can see that white really plays
with an attacking style like I said I
will put a link in the description below
to an interview with young Chi Chuan
from January 2010 18 feel free to check
it out it's really you you definitely
want to learn more about this young
fellow as I'm pretty sure we'll be
seeing much more of him so II five a
very nice move releasing the bishop here
now the bishop is I in this g6 pawn but
also the dark square Bishop is ready to
jump to h6 so here now if I shook
spidey-sense it doesn't start tingling
and that is a problem here you want to
capture on c3 after you capture pawn
captures Knight captures here the Queen
is under attack you have to move the
Queen and after Queen to g3 it's very
hard to see what white had in mind after
this ePHI move after the knight blocks
here you will either capture this bishop
this bishop is now blocked the knight is
a monster on d3 black is having a very
an excellent game here and on the other
hand you could try some tricks for
example after Bishop captures on c3 you
could try the intermediate Bishop
captures and g6 and say that okay and
that bug a person C to remove wasn't
very good but it doesn't work because
now when the bishop is here you have
Knight captures on e5 and this Knight to
e5 is the main defensive idea of event
you in this position
now the Queen is under attack and also
the bishop so here you have to give a
double check Knight captures on h7 King
captures on h7 but now after Queen to h3
trick King to g8 now Queen to g3 check
here you will play Knight to g4 you
black is hoping that white will grab the
night so you can bring the best robe
back to g7 as the bishop will be a much
more useful defensive piece now but here
be Capra's on c3 will be played and now
Queen to d7 defending the night and
after h3 yes white will win that night
back but after 94 attacking the Queen
captures captures and now after the
queen is captured the black has queen
Knights to g3 check
one night captures clean chapters and
you are left with two rooks against a
rook and the bishop white would be upon
up but it's a double Jeep on basically
black would be would have an inning a
winning endgame here
so after this if I move event to has all
the resources needed to stop this but
his spidey sense doesn't doesn't go
tingling and he plays a bunch of
characters on e5 he wants to keep his
dark square Bishop to go back to g7 you
don't want to this Bishop coming to h6
it could be a problem but now as we've
already mentioned the main defensive
idea black head was bringing this nice
to e5 from there it would attack the
Queen and also protected the g6 pawn
here if I choose Bishop is on e5 so
night if I will no longer be possible
and here young Sri chuan takes this
opportunity and plays Bishop captures
and g6 and now even she could still hope
to survive this after after something
like rook to a fade Bishop to a5 check a
king to h8 maybe now you can still play
this may be the knight then come to have
sex maybe you can use the semi open G
file to attack right here
perhaps the black would still have
chances but if one should boldly
captured the Bishop H captures on g6 and
now comes Queen captures on g6 Bushra
back to g7 you want to saw all of this
and most likely he saw everything that
follows because Queen to f7 was played
King to h8 and here most likely event
you saw that here you can't play rook to
f3 to finish the game because here our
rook to e1 simply doesn't work I mean I
mean rocked f3 doesn't work because the
rook do you want you have to bring the
room back and now after Queen to h4 you
you guard the rook you defend the d h5
square and also the other look is not
ready to enter the game even she would
be winning here but he missed one idea
from Yong Chi Chuan so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find it
the idea
Chucky's missed I'll give you a couple
of seconds you know if you want if you
want to give it a go
so okay for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations you have just
found an idea of a the great vastly
bunch of mist over the board and for
those
who just want to enjoy the show now the
strong move is actually Queen to h5
check and it's a really nice idea
you pull the king back but you also
protect the g5 square which is very
important
King g8 and now comes Bishop to g5 now
this comes with an attack on the Queen
so you're not wasting any time here
Bishop to g5 is played and also now
you've connected rooks
so now rook to f3 will be a very strong
resource as now the other rook is
controlling d1 square and here even
triplet Queen to see it but it's no
better to block with the rock rock e7
here simply Queen to h4 you go for the
rook Knight of six blocks captures
captures and captures and here you will
not be able to fend off everything White
is ready to throw away this rock is
coming to f1 ro G 6 is an idea
black will not be able to survive this
so if I should try to Queen to c8 but
now comes Queen to f7 check King to h8
and now that the rooks are connected the
same idea applies so rook to a4 and here
there is no defense against the rook to
h4 checkmate will will soon follow so I
mean you could try something but nothing
really works if you try to bring the
knight back into the defense with Knight
to f6 you're still getting Bishop
captures here there's there's really
really nothing to do here but captures
and still Queen captures on f6 again
you're getting and just just hammered
here rope is coming to H for checking g8
rocket-shaped
only only one of the variations that
work but yeah
Queen to f7 King moves and now Luka for
at the 26th move so really we can call
this a modern miniature and the
brilliant one is that now unto those two
reasons that I've already mentioned why
I wasn't gonna show this game because I
decided not to show it before ever
seeing the game I've seen everyone
posting I want to cook the upset of the
tournament already in round 1 but even
Chuck has been losing our games lately
and he's basically been throwing away
his rating to lower radius players and I
was like yeah I mean I'd be more
impressed with an upset where were event
would come
instantly win a game against a strong
player because something lately just
doesn't work for him I personally think
he's playing too much chess I think he
want to be playing like eight leagues or
something like that he's constantly
traveling constantly playing chess and
that's simply not possible for a chess
player I don't think it's his age he's
the exact same age as Anand he's 49 so I
don't think that would be such a problem
but then I saw the game and then I saw
that young schrieffer Marillac Shikari
actually if a brilliant attacking game
that it wasn't some big blunder by von
Schuch so I was very happy for the young
player I mean really a vicious attack
after this 'if I've if you don't realize
what the dangers of this are and even
should really missed only a tiny bit of
this variation that makes the attack
possible but still it is a brilliancy
and should be regarded as such so that's
basically it once again
do check out the interview with the
young gentleman it will be the first
thing you will see in the description
below
really it there video only has 902 views
so really should do better than that
and I did use their photo so it would
only be fair if you have the time but
yeah I would like to thank Kristian
Kristian Bokova Archer clay Archer clay
Prussian sharma and John head linger for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos your
thing called for watching and I will see
you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content thank you all and I'll see you
soon